hey guys hey going my name is dumb and
welcome to a pug tutorial so bye pug I
don't mean the dog I actually mean the
HTML preprocessor now this means that
it's basically a language that will
convert itself into native HTML code and
you want to use Pug because it is
arguably a lot cleaner to read and also
code in and it features some extra
powerful functionality such as loops
JavaScript objects JavaScript logic
mix-ins templates and so on so to
actually use pug you can do so by
installing the pug command line
interface and this is done using NPM the
node package manager so inside your
terminal you want to tap out NPM and
they install this is assuming that you
actually have node installed on your
machine for stopping an NPM install and
then typing a pug - CLI the Pug
command-line interface you can install
poke you might want to also add the dash
G flag to make that install globally now
once that's done you will have Punk
accessible via the command line by
topping out Punk alright so in today's
video I want to go over my directory
structure and how I'm going to you know
code things in the future so here I've
got a folder called intro and I'm going
to make a new directory inside here I'm
gonna call this one HTML this will
contain all the native HTML output that
was generated by poke alright I press
ENTER right here now I'm also going to
create a new pug source file inside the
root directory alright so I'm going to
say ok new file and call this one index
hug okay this will be translated to
index dot HTML inside the HTML directory
okay
now the most basic or
the most common pug commands you might
see like the most common syntax is the
doctype and in HTML and that right there
in park will generate the doctype first
little statement on the top of your HTML
page all right so to actually compile
this pug code into HTML we can start by
using the pug command line interface so
down here I'm inside the routes intro
directory okay I'm gonna talk about PUC
alright and then also add the dash W
flag that means it's the watch flag it's
going to watch for any file changes I
make once I press save it's going to
compile automatically without me doing
anything I'm also going to watch that
file or what are the files we're going
to watch everything in the current
directory so doc for slash everything in
this root directory alright I'm also
going to say where the output will be
it's gonna be inside this HTML folder so
I'm going to say - o and then say dot
forward slash HTML so I'll put all my
stuff inside the HTML folder okay
I'm also gonna say - and then capital P
and that will make the HTML code pretty
printed with indentation line breaks and
all that sort of stuff if I press ENTER
right now we get it says watching
indexed up park so I make a change is
going to compile it's going to render
the HTML called index.html copying the
same file name from the pug for name
okay so now inside this HTML folder
I see index dot HTML I press on that and
we get that doctype HTML you know
statement up there okay and that is how
you can use Park Hae you compile Park
now you can structure your plug
directories in the future I'm gonna make
use of this sort of structure and
obviously show you guys that
to use this thing
so in this one I want to talk about how
to generate your own HTML tags and also
how to insert different doctype
declarations but first keep in mind that
I'm using the pug watcher so when I save
a pug file it's going to generate the
corresponding output HTML file inside
the HTML directory okay so it's like
this pug file we can create or generate
a duck type using the duck type shortcut
so I'm going to say doctoral but that
and then say HTML with a space and that
what there will generate the standard
html5 doctype declaration so if I save
this one inside the output file we get
that right there okay perfect
we also got things such as XML so for
example doctype XML we get the XML
declaration we have also the
transitional one save this one we get
that right there we have strict all
right and also a few more which you can
see inside the private documentation so
I'll make this back to HTML that's the
most probably common one to see and
probably what you're gonna work with so
with this we're going to start creating
some HTML tags now in regulate Simo to
make the HTML tag you type out all right
HTML opening and an HTML closing okay
with bug it's literally just less than
half this amount of coding so in pug you
talked about HTML like that and it's
going to generate both the opening and
closing tag for you if the closing tag
is required so if I save this one we get
in the output 'html like that pretty
cool so that's that I'm actually making
HTML tag you just talked about boom the
HTML tag name now to actually add a
child elements of another parent element
for example adding the head tag inside
here we can do that by first indenting
on a new line
so press enter here and then an indent
okay here we put the name of the child
element or child tag so typing at head
right here and saving this one will give
us the desired output for example boom
HTML and then head inside there if all
to get rid of the Indian make that onto
the first character yeah like that if I
save this one we get no errors but in
here we get them on two separate lines
they're two separate elements not
connected in one bit so make sure you
use an indent for child elements it's
very important okay
so we'll do the same thing for the body
tag just like that save this one and we
get this output right there
pretty straightforward now in the body
I'm gonna make a few tags some h1 set
some peas and also some unordered lists
okay so it's right here gonna press
ENTER and add a new indents for a child
element I'm gonna make an h1 tag h1 save
this one check the output and we get
that right there now to actually put
text inside here we can do so quite
easily using pug we'll put a space in
front of the tag name and then Watson
text for example
welcome to decode okay I'll save this
one we get that but they're perfect now
let's read a paragraph tag so below here
I'm gonna make a new paragraph tag now
if I was to say okay this is a paragraph
tag that works fine we see that right
there now if I want to actually have
multiple lines of text if I tapia and
this is a new
save this one and we get this a bit
funny so it's it's saying and as a as a
tag name and playing that text inside
there inside the and tag so to actually
generate some multi-line text using pug
you put a full-stop after the element
name or the tag name like that and then
you drop your text on to the second line
indent it and now you have your
multi-line text okay so now we have this
right here if I save this one the
airport looks like this which was our
intention okay so you use that dot for
multi-line and put it on the second line
and also indents it okay
now you might commonly see unordered
lists or lists in general on hug
examples or documentation so to actually
make a list we can do so using the UL
and order this tag and then put some
child elements inside yeah we say oh I
for list item yep this is item one and
then so on okay two and then three
we save this one and we get that right
there okay so pretty straightforward
stuff and quite interesting so it looks
a bit like sass I guess there's no
braces no you know angle brackets or
quite clean and simple
so in this one I want to talk about how
to add IDs and classes to HTML elements
so just keep in mind that I have a pug
watcher have been run now which means
when I saved this index park file it
will automatically generate the output
file inside the HTML directory under
index dot HTML all right so let's get
right into it we can start by making a
simple HTML joking with a doctype at
opening HTML tag a head tag and also a
body tag all right so if I save this one
we get this India all right so let's
define a h1 header tag and give it an ID
now we can do this using CSS selector
syntax all right this means I can
actually go inside here and I can say
okay first to clear the element name for
example h1 then a hash tag followed by
the ID okay so I'm gonna say h1 hash tag
and there's something like page sorry
page title alright and did something
like page title goes here now as the
content so if I was to save this one in
the output we see that paginates the h1
with an ID of page title automatically
for us so that's quite convenient right
there and we can do the same thing with
classes once again using the CSS
selector syntax so down here I'm gonna
make a few paragraphs and give it the
same class name so we'll say okay P
declare the element name followed by a
full stop by a dot to define or declare
this is a is gonna be a class so P dot
and then at the class name for example
something like big para and then some
text so AB dot and we'll say he is some
kicks for my big paragraph okay so now
if I was to copy this one
and do some more so here is some more
text okay so now we have two paragraph
tags with an O with a class name so if I
saved this one in the output we get that
right there okay once again quite
convenient now we can also do something
where we don't actually declare what the
element type is okay so false to go down
here under this paragraph Tokyo and I
was to say something like something like
a display box
okay so display box as a class with no
element here all right if I just save
this for more quickly and check the
output we get a div with a class of
display box so why is that well in pug
what it does is that actually um there
are actually default any classes or any
IDs that you don't specify an element
with as a div so it knows that a div is
a common element to use so if you talk
about the class name with no actual you
know yeah
it'll make a div conveniently for you to
try and guess what you actually meant if
that makes sense
you can of course just top out div and
you'll have the same effects all right
and the same thing works with IDs as
well so down here I can say okay my only
div for example if I save this one we
get the div ID my only div alright so
that is how you can declare classes and
ID's on your elements using Punk
so in this one I want to talk about how
to add attributes to HTML elements and
also talk about some of the advanced
features that you'll find in pug in
relation to attributes so I just keep in
mind that I have the the pug command
line tool running with the watch flag
which means that when I save this index
pug file it's going to generate the
index.html file inside the HTML
directory alright so let's start inside
here I've got a doctype HTML tag head
and then body
ok so let's demonstrate attributes using
an input element so we'll say okay buddy
and then add an input field right there
if I save this one and check the output
we start with that right there so let's
make this input field a password field
and to give it a name so back inside
here
let's put braces next to the input field
sorry input tag and then write out some
attributes so say okay input and give it
a type of password so this syntax is the
same as HTML once you get inside the
bracket so that's saying input type
password I'll save this one and check
the output we get that right there as
expected okay now we can add multiple
attributes to a HTML element by putting
a space after that so you can say okay
type is password and the name is INPE
PWD so if i save this one and check the
output we get both attributes there
perfect
all right now in terms of the advanced
features of Pug with attributes one of
them is the the use of JavaScript inside
the attribute value so for example let's
make a new attribute and we call this
one data
- jeaious or JavaScript
you know as an example equal to now here
we're gonna use an ECMAScript 2015
string string literal so let's put two
tactics down here and inside here we can
embed we can embed an expression so put
a dollar sign followed by two curly
braces now inside here we can put some
JavaScript logic or an expression so
let's say something like this we'll say
if five is greater than 2 then we want
to make the data jeaious attribute value
something like okay otherwise let's make
the value not okay right so now if I
save this one and check the output we
get data jeaious is equal to okay and
that's because five years greater than 2
let's make this if one is greater than
two saving this one we get it is not
okay all right so you can add JavaScript
expressions or logic inside your
attribute values all right so pretty
cool in it now now you can also add
classes to an element all at once so
let's go down here make a new element
we'll make a new div tag
okay now up here though let's define a
new JavaScript
let's first actually in Denmark Oh
properly put that down there
alright so let's create a new JavaScript
array we can add a dash here and that
means that this line is gonna be a
JavaScript line that's - and they will
say Const
my classes is equal to a typical array
of strings all right so let's put an
array here inside of yo we'll put the
few elements we can say okay plus 1 plus
1 plus 2 and then class 3 all right so
here we have defined a JavaScript array
using the - alright now we can add all
these classes
do this development like this we can say
okay once again using the braces we can
say class so the class attributes
similar to that right there is then
equal to simply then my classes so if I
save this one in the output we get a div
and a class attribute of all these
classes but they're separated by a space
okay so quite convenient now if else to
go back inside here and add a class to
the beginning of this elements the
traditional way so div and then dot
something like I don't know my depth
okay if I save this one we're defining a
class here and also more classes inside
here like that the airport looks like
this we keep the initial my div class so
that means that that right there is
going to append to the current class
list I so keep that in mind now we can
do a similar sort of thing with inline
styles so down here let's make a new div
once again and up here let's make a new
javascript object so once again using
the dash to signify a line of JavaScript
we can say okay
- and then punched my Styles inside here
in this object we can then define the
CSS styles using javascript objects
syntax so we can say ok let's make the
text color as Reds put a comma let's set
the background color it's gonna be blue
alright now down here we could do
virtually the same thing we can say okay
div and then style its equal to my stars
alright saving this one gives us that
right there so we have this style
attribute and then all these CSS Styles
formatted nice and nearly for us okay so
once again very convenient now we
can also do again a similar thing using
the attributes so we can actually define
attributes as a JavaScript object and
then put that on the actual element
itself so let's make once again a new
element this time let's make it an image
element so IMG okay come up here let's
define a new constant okay constants my
attributes
once again equal to a javascript object
so we'll say okay my attributes let's
put the attributes as a javascript
object so we'll say okay SRC sauce is
gonna be my photo dot PNG the alt text
will be pcs my photo okay now to
actually add this to the element we can
put an ampersand okay attributes within
brackets and pass in my attributes right
here so a similar thing to the above
examples but this song were actually
using the and attribute syntax instead
of a you know a bracket alright now if I
save this one what do we get well we get
boom that right there give me sauce my
photo alt X this is my photo perfect
alright so once again very convenient
now one more thing let's talk about
boolean attributes so things such as
input type you know text and then have
that being disabled or something like
input type the check box and then make
that check so those those single word
boolean attributes okay
so Dan yeah let's make a new input
fields okay Cupid eight type of you know
just text normal and let's make that
text field disabled we can say okay
disabled no need for a equals and then
something else just disabled and then
pug will automatically add that to the
absolutely
let us save this one what do we get we
get that word top text and it's disabled
now what if I was to change the duck
type for this document to something like
transition I know
transitional does not support the single
single word attributes so if I save this
one what happens we'll check the output
and this time we get disabled equals
disabled so pug is going to
automatically make sure that the output
is valid for the actual document type
which is obviously quite cool you know
what one last thing with the attributes
you can say okay disable it then equals
false so goes away or true so keep that
in mind all right boom right there
so in this one I want to talk about how
to work with CSS within your Pug HTML
files this includes external CSS
internal CSS and also inline CSS so
let's get started just keep in mind that
I have the pug watch chart running which
means that when I saved an index Park
file it gets outputted inside index.html
inside the HTML directory alright so the
index pug file let's start by declaring
a document type
so we'll say all right doctype HTML
saving this gives us that in the airport
alright let's begin with some HTML tags
HTML heads and also a body now to
include an internal sorry an external
CSS file it's the same as doing it with
regular HTML except it actually going to
be adding the element using poke
so let's first create a CSS file inside
the HTML directory so we'll say okay new
file call this one style dot CSS let's
give the body a background color of
black let's give it a font size of 36
pixels and a font color of white
all right so now we're going to include
this CSS file inside this index.html
file ok so inside your head tag you want
to make a new link element and give it a
few attributes the first one being
around equal to stylesheet okay make a
second one called href equal to star CSS
saving this one generates in HTML a
normal link element with two attributes
rel and a trip now inside the HTML
directory we've got style a CSS and also
index to HTML so this is relative to the
actual directory right there so now this
H
if I was to add some text inside the
body just say one paragraph saying this
is an HTML file saving this one gives us
that result right there in the browser
we get boom that right there so
everything works as expected
okay so that is how you can use external
CSS with pub now internal CSS is
essentially the same thing as normal
HTML internal CSS but using the pub
syntax to create a multi-line element so
back inside the head tag we can create a
new style element so we'll say alright
style okay
then put a dot two so this is going to
be a multi-line HTML element putting an
enter than a tab we can now start
declaring our CSS rules so let's add
some more rules for a paragraph tag so
we'll say okay P and make the text color
as being red and give it a
text-decoration:underline all right so
now saving this one gives us this result
in HTML style and then that P star block
right there in the browser we obviously
get boom benefits okay now for internal
sorry inline CSS we can do once again a
very similar thing by going inside the
index pack file and putting an attribute
on the actual paragraph tag this will be
the style attribute then we can do this
one of two ways
we can first do it the I guess normal
way by putting a double quote and
putting the actual Styles inside here
for example let's just say that will
give the text-align:center and we'll
also give it an upper case
transformation so text transform and
then upper case alright saving this
gives us this in the HTML inside the
actual browser we obviously get boom
those effects right there now we can
also do it a separate way now we can do
this also using a JavaScript object so
let's define a new javascript object
within pub by putting a dash and then
writing the JavaScript on this line
let's make a new constant and call this
one P stars okay that's going to be
equal to an object literal and slightly
we're going to give these CSS properties
using key value pair so let's just say
let's define a new property called
text-align okay with the value of center
I do the same thing for text transform
uppercase perfect so now we have this
javascript object we can actually insert
this into this style attribute by
getting rid of all this stuff including
the double quotes and simply just saying
key stars now pipe is going to read this
object and then convert that into normal
CSS so saving this one gives us that in
the HTML we can see we get the formatted
CSS there actually might be a problem
yeah give me one sec okay what does it
say unexpected token okay so got a give
a double quote there and fix that up
horatii
now that is a valid object we can save
this and now in HTML we get that
formatted CSS the way it should be
okay now saving this in the browser we
get the same effect okay and that is how
you can use CSS with your hug HTML files
so in this one I want to talk about the
each loop and the each loop it basically
allows you to loop over an array or an
object and then output 'html
and the each loop is the same as the for
loop except that the for loop is
different names so each and for these
two loops are exactly the same that it's
got a different name okay so keep that
in mind so let's get right into this
I'm just keep in mind that I have the
hugged watcher running which means that
when I save this index POG file it's
going to output that inside the HTML
directory okay so if I'll start out okay
doctype HTML then add the basic HTML
tags head and then body saving this
gives me this in this file right there
okay so let's start with this H / for
loop I'll begin with an h1 tag and we're
just say okay for slash each loop okay
now down here we're gonna use the each
loop to output the numbers one two five
I'm the actual you know in the in HTML
so the syntax is as follows you start
with the each keyword followed by the
the name of the temporary variable that
will hold H value so for example each
and then in short for number and then
you write out in so saying each n or
each number in your array so we'll talk
about one two three four and five okay
and now inside here we'll just indent
this and then we'll top it will make a
new paragraph tag and just put n inside
there okay actually near to put an equal
sign that way we actually apples an HTML
sorry the equals allows you to output
the extra value instead of the number n
so it fails to get rid of this equals
and save this one we
and and and and having the equals there
means that it's gonna interpret this end
as the actual variable up here so now
saving this gives us that right there
one two three four five and this is done
only with a simple loop so obviously
this is quite useful for you're dealing
with the data especially okay now let's
just um let's just also look at getting
the value as well as the index in your
array so we have here the actual values
okay they also change this to the number
50 for example saving this gives us 50
and then two three four so these are the
actual values now to get the actual
index of whatever the the item is at
that current point in time you put a
comma here a comma and then your
variable for the index
I'll just call mine I so now the current
index is stored inside the I variable
okay
now this means that we can actually do
this we can say okay in and then put a
plus and then we can just say something
like - and then plus I so now we're
gonna see the value and then a - and
then the index and now saving this gives
us this in the output 50 at index 0 1 2
3 4 and so on
so that's how to access the value and
index now just keep in mind that this is
basically just JavaScript here I can
actually declare an array outside of
them outside of this this each loop here
so I can put a dash here and declare a
JavaScript array for example let's just
make a new constant and call this one
names equal to an array of strings of
name so for example we'll have one full
of Dom Sofie and in marks we have we
have three names yet you know I can
actually go inside here and replace that
one but
with instead names so now it's gonna
loop through everything in this names
array so saving this gives us that right
there Dom at index 0 31 and then mark
and 2 so pretty cool stuff so that's the
arrays this thing also actually works on
objects as well so if else to get with
this array here and instead let's just
put something like maybe great so make a
new object called greats equal to an
object literal and put some some grades
for your university courses inside here
for example let's just say I will say
for web web development web dev you've
got a five percent for something like
software design
you've got 76 percent so we have two
properties in this in this object all
right so now if you save this we get
okay that didn't work let's see the
output what does it say length of under
archive course so got to put Dre's
inside here all right so now saving this
one it gives us that in the airport we
get we get the actual value and then the
index so in this case here the index
will be the actual property name and the
value will be the actual value of that
property so we're saying okay 85 web
depth then that four suffer design all
right so if I was to actually change
this from each into four and save this
we get the exact same result let's just
change this from 85 to a hundred to
disprove this save it again and we get
100 right there so the each and the fall
are just the same thing with a different
name
okay now this thing actually it also
comes with an else and the elves will
run whenever
there's actually no values to iterate
the route so it falls to go down here
and go back and just say okay apps all
right down here let's just put a strong
tag and inside there we'll just we'll
just say something like no loop possible
or maybe maybe no values okay let's get
move those quotes well so now what's
gonna happen is if there are no values
to actually loop through it's gonna
print it out no values are here let's
just get rid of this grades all right D
look at this grades and inside here we
put an empty array an empty array saving
this gives us boom that right there
strong no values are here so it skips
this part and just says okay we can't do
anything so print it up no values are
here and that is how you can use the
four slash each loop within park
I want to talk about conditionals in a
pug so essentially the most common type
of conditional is an if statement so
with an if statement you're able to do
things based on a certain condition
otherwise do something else so for
example if a user is logged in you want
to say hi how are you welcome back if
they're logged out you want to say hey
going do one login so essentially you're
able to do different things based on a
certain condition so let's see how this
thing works I've got a basic HTML
template right now we have that in the
actual output alright so inside the body
tag let's make a new h2 tag and just say
my web application if I save this in the
browser we get this result right here
all right
quite simple now let's add a conditional
statement to display different things if
a user is logged in or logged out so
let's first start by defining a
JavaScript object to actually represent
the user so I'll put a dash here and
then say let user a new variable equal
to an object this object contains three
properties firstly the name of the
actual user Boggs Airport Dominic
alright and then a logged in boolean to
represent game logged in state for now
I'm going to say that actually not
loggers like I said logged in equal to
false all right the third argument or
third sorry the third property will be
last login
so last login we're going to say it was
six minutes ago so somehow using cookies
or sessions were able to discover that
their name is Dominic they're currently
not logged in and their last login was
six minutes ago all right so now with
this object we're going to output
different HTML and based on different
property values so
the first one is going to be if they're
logged in we're gonna say hi welcome
back and then their name so let's go
down here and write an if statement so
we're going to say okay if and then tap
out user dot logged in so if the user is
logged in then I want an output by
indenting some HTML will make a
paragraph tag and then indent this to
add some child elements to this
paragraph we're gonna say okay
put a pipe character and say welcome
back
okay now this pipe character means that
I want to ignore all this all this
output sorry all this text and make it
actual plain text and not an HTML tag if
I was to remove the actual pipe then
it's gonna make a welcome element okay
so put a pipe to ensure that this is
interpreted as plain text now down here
I'm gonna put a strong tag I'm gonna say
strong all right and then interpolate
this and pass in user dot name okay so
now with this we are essentially saying
if the user is logged in then say
welcome back and then a put their name
in bolt okay so now I'm going to just
actually you know what I'll change this
logged in state to true and then save
this and then we'll see the actual
output right so now if I save it the
output looks like this
welcome back Dominic okay so we see how
the condition works if I'll make this
false and then say this one refresh the
browser and we get nothing at all so
you're seeing how it actually works here
let's just keep it our thoughts for now
okay now I'm gonna add an else alright
so down here get in debt back to the
actual if line all right and then say
else so now this this block will execute
when
this is not true so we're gonna say okay
if they're not logged in then display a
anchor link element with an href of
login okay and say login so now so now
it's saying okay you're not logged in so
display a link which links you to the
login page and says login so now saving
this we get this in the browser refresh
log in okay again making this equal to
true say this we get that
so it's switching based on this
condition right there is actually a is
actually a third one quarter an else--if
so you're able to put an else if between
the if and the house so we're gonna use
this last login property here to add an
else if and say okay if the user logged
in less than ten minutes ago then we're
just gonna say login again so let's put
an else if inside here okay we're gonna
say okay else if and then put down if
the user the last login is less than ten
minutes ago all right we're gonna set
okay a new paragraph tag inside here oh
I think I'm just gonna say okay your
last login your last login once I've
been put down user and say minutes ago
and then we're gonna tell them do you
want to log in again so then say okay
add a new paragraph tag inside here and
make a new link tag and say H ref log in
on last time login again so now if their
last login was less than 10 minutes ago
we're gonna say okay your last login was
that value their minutes ago all right
we're gonna say okay login again so now
right now we're saying they're not
logged in that were actually run
okay then we can say okay if that's not
true then we're gonna run this
I'll see if last leg in this in six
minutes ago sorry less than 10 minutes
ago we're gonna display that right there
so now if we save this one in the
browser we get this right here your last
login was six minutes ago login again
so it's checking the first one that's
not true then do this if that's not true
then do this so I'll make this 11 okay
11 is more than 10 so now this won't
even run and we should get this final
else block if I save this what do we get
refreshed we get loggia all right and
that is how you can use conditionals in
park
I talked about the case statement in pug
so essentially the case statement is
just like the normal JavaScript switch
statement so you're able to do different
things based on the value of a variable
or some sort of expression so in this
case here with pug it's gonna be you're
able to change some HTML based on some
sort of comparison so let's see how this
thing works I've got a simple HTML
markup here with HTML tag head and body
and a title inside the index.html we get
that result right there so now inside
the body we're going to use a case
statement so we can start by defining a
new JavaScript a constant and call this
one order status ok now this right here
will be the status of some sort of order
so for example the order status might be
pending okay and this status might be
things such as such as pending it could
be in transit so I'll just write these
down we have pending it can be in
transit and it can also be completed so
we're going to look at these these these
values here and then output different
HTML based on what value the order
status is so below here we're gonna use
the case statement it looks like this
you write out case followed by the thing
to actually compare against in this case
here we're gonna compare against or out
of status okay and then you put a line
break then a tab and now you write uh
something like this you say when so
using the when keyword you then write
out an actual value here for example
pending
so it's kind of like English we're
saying okay we're checking the order
status when it is pending we want to do
stuff here okay so let's say for example
I put it um we'll do a paragraph tag and
say your order has been placed and
you'll be sent shortly okay we can do
another one for the in transit value
okay
this one here is gonna be your order is
on the moon you should receive it soon
okay and then one more just will be
completed paragraph to say your order
your order has been completed okay so
now we have the case statement all done
so it's gonna check the value of order
status and then do different things
based on the actual value so now inside
the outputted HTML what do we get we get
your order has been placed and will be
set
shortly that's because currently the
order status is equal to pending if I
change this to in transit and then save
this we now get on the move you should
receive it soon and then obviously we
change it to complete it we get your
order has been completed so you can see
how it's actually working here right now
what if I make the value here something
random such as random okay Brandon isn't
in this list and it's not being compared
down here so what happens now well if I
save this we get nothing so we actually
get no output from that case statement
to actually resolve this we can use the
default keyword and default means what
happens when the value is not one of
these okay so if it's not pending not in
transit and not completed we're gonna do
this instead okay in that case we'll
just find out something like sorry
we aren't sure what happens with your
oil okay so now if we say this one sure
enough we get that message right there
all right and the same thing works with
numbers just make this you know one two
and then so on have this as two and we
should get that one right there you see
how it works Oh numbers strings whatever
you want it works and that's how you can
use the case statement in pack
that the include keyword in pug so
essentially the include keyword allows
you to include other Park files inside
your Pug file and it's very useful when
you have multiple HTML pages that share
the same HTML so things such as headers
navigation bars and footers that sort of
stuff and includes might be quite useful
so let's see how this thing works I've
got an index dot pod file here I'm just
going to create a new h1 tag inside the
body and give it something like a
company name okay and also make a
navigation bar with a few links inside
here like a new 8a give it a href of
something like index.html and have that
be home to the same thing two more times
for our belt that'll be about us and
this one can be contact us but I have
the actual hash for the ice right here
so now if I was to save this calc file
the output looks like this we get that
right there in the browser we actually
get something like this refresh and we
get that so now this navigation bar
company name is going to be repeated
across multiple pages on this website so
we're going to use and includes to
actually do that but first I want to
show you what it looks like if I was to
create a new about Park file and just
copy/paste all of this stuff into here
and then just have something like about
as the twaddle and just have a new
header tag below here with about us okay
so yeah if I save this and then check
the browser I'll just click on this
about link and we get that right there
so we have the about page here back to
home and we get that so we've got
actually our move this section right
here the h1 and the navigation bar into
a separate includes file which will then
be repeated
across both the index page and also the
about page all right so we can do this
by first just making a new directory
inside this this project book here
can I call this directory includes okay
I'm gonna install all my includes files
inside here to keep things neat
so now inside this directory gonna make
a new pug source file and call this one
nerve tuck okay now open this up inside
here I'm gonna put that h1 and the
navigation so I'll copy all this and
then put it inside naviga
just make that all nice and neat once
again okay so now we have navigation
inside here let's just put that back one
more time okay so now navigation is
inside here back inside the about park
file under the body I'm going to tuck
this yep I'm gonna say includes okay
using that include keyword followed by
the B path to actually include for
example in our case it will be includes
forward slash nav so includes the actual
directory name and nav is the name of
the pug farm you can do this with or
without the dot plug extension it's up
to you okay so now I'm gonna save that
and do the same thing for the index page
okay get rid of that and paste in
include right there so now these pages
are going to get the pug that's inside
this nav file and just insert it right
into place right there so now if I was
to save this and just check the actual
console here we get no errors oops all
right okay now in actual in actual
browser or so refresh this time we get
the same result so see how the same
thing is happening however this time
around I can actually I can actually go
inside the nav Park file if I make a
change inside here it's gonna change it
across
all the all the HTML pages at for
example let's say I want to add a
different link to the actual navigation
bar if I add a gallery to this will say
gallery and call that gallery okay if I
save this now we should hopefully see
the result in the browser for refresh
and we get gallery right there okay so
going back to the home page now so the
the about page we get gallery as well so
I'm making one change and to tag files
are being updated and that is the power
of the include keyword alright and
that's how you can use include in bug
so in this one I want to talk about
mix-ins and mixings are basically just
reusable blocks of pub code and they
behave like functions you can actually
call these mixings throughout your pub
project and even passing data as
argument so dynamic data from your
database or whatever you can pass it in
as arguments and then the mixin will
actually render the HTML with those
arguments so they behave very similar to
functions so let's see how this thing
actually works we're going to use an
example of a typical website comment so
a comment has things such as an author a
date and also the actual comment text
itself and we're going to use their
mixing to actually render a comment so
on a post or video there might be heaps
of comments just say 5 to 100 comments
and you can use they mix in to to
produce the same HTML structure for all
those comments but have different data
so let's first start by actually
designing the common HTML first so
inside the body let's create a new
wrapper for a comment so let's make a
div with a past 5 comment just like that
this div has three child elements the
first one being the comments date and
let's just say the date was for example
the 2nd of April okay and we can have
one for the actual author so water so
that class of author keep it value of
decode me for example and also one more
for this hits this would be the actual
comment itself for example came a nice
tutorial ok so now if I was to save this
inside the HTML directory we have a new
index.html file and the output looks
like this if I was to go in the browser
and refresh we get that right there
so that is basically the structure of
the comet designed in HTML let's just
add some simple styles to make it look
better all right let's make a new start
egg up here in the head and create a new
style I still sit for the comment class
give it a fun family of sans-serif our
line height of 1.5 let's give some
padding about 10 pixels okay and a
border of 1 pixel solid and dark gray
and also we've got 250 pixels all right
now for the actual dates let's make this
a bit smaller so we'll say date a class
of date let's give it a font size of 85%
all right for the author let's give a
font size of a bit larger something like
budget in 10% and a font weight of the
bold and also for the actual text itself
let's just say font size 100 percent a
little bit the default value anyway well
that's fine if I was to save this and
refresh the browser this time we get
that right there so we have the comet
structure in HTML and also some stars
I'll just add for the date they text the
line of the rights to get that to the
right side say this refresh and we get
that right there perfect so now we have
the actual structure we can now move
this into a mixing alright and that'll
let us actually reuse this same
structure for whatever values we want
later on ok so on the top of this pug
file let's declare a mixin we can do
this by using the mixing keyword so
we'll say mixing followed by a space and
then the name of the mix itself in this
case here let's call our mixing comments
ok now as I said this mixing can contain
or accept arguments extra data
we can put these arguments inside a
brace let's accept one argument that
will be comment data so now we can
reference this comment data argument as
a typical JavaScript object within the
actual mixing itself
so now after an indent inside here this
mixin we can put whatever pub code we
want alright so for example let's render
first the comment wrapper so I will say
dot comment so I did with the class of
comment okay now down here we can start
to render some dynamic values from this
comment data argument so inside here
let's copy all this stuff right here so
copy this paste it inside there and fix
that up so now for these values right we
can say this instead we put an equals to
get some buffered output and we can say
comment data dot dates all right down
here the same thing comment data
same thing for the bottom one equals and
then comment data dot text okay so now
the mixin is complete we have this
reusable structure with some dynamic
data coming from the argument okay so
now both to save this and go down here
alright and I'm gonna replace all of
this stuff right here with a mixin call
but first let's just declare a
JavaScript object to actually be the
comment data so down here let's put a
dash right here and say make a new
constant and call this one C equal to a
JavaScript object let's give it some
values we need dates author and text so
down here let's target a
once again we can say it was the 2nd of
April so Oh - so I have a 402 2018 let's
give it the author property of decode
and the texts let's just say the same
thing hey mate great tutorials ok
boom so now the falls to go down here we
can now call this mixing and you call a
mix in by putting the plus alright
followed by the mixing name in our case
it'll be comical so plus and then
comment that right there now we can pass
in the data in this case here that will
be C C is going to be the JavaScript
object to pass into this comment it's
going to be rendered up here so now if I
was to save this and refresh the browser
this time around we get the same thing
with a replaced comment data okay so we
can see how it's actually working if I
was to go down here and make a new
comment object and copy that right there
paste it inside there let's change the
date to 2020 and we'll make it something
like this
2nd of July the author will be our anode
Bruce all right and the text can be that
was save this and then actually let's
just call the actual mixing again so
plus comment passing see oh let's just
make this C 1 all right
C 1 that was a constant so now if I was
to save this refresh your browser boom
we get two comments while only writing
the HTML what so that's the advantage of
using mix-ins now just keep in mind that
these mixin solicit can actually contain
any form of you know pug features so for
example let's actually put an if
statement within this mixin let's say
that some comments can be posted by an
admin user and in that case we want
something like a message on top here
that says this was posted by an admin so
let's just go back you saw the code here
and create an if statement inside this
comment okay we can say if comment data
got posted by admin so if it was posted
by an admin I'm gonna render a new I
italic Thor let's use an am so then an
AM tag to produce italic text and give
it the the text of posted by admin okay
so now if this comment was posted by an
admin render that right there so now
within this code down here let's say the
first comment has the posted by admin
property with a value of true okay so
now for us to save this one and refresh
the browser we get hosted by admin
within that comment there because it has
the actual property right there so you
can see that the mixin supports all the
types of park features not just
rendering HTML by itself alright and
that is how you can use mixings
in pug thank you for watching and I'll
see you later